well three square food pantry is the
largest food distribution center right
here in the valley and now they need
your help yeah in fact they serve more
than a hundred thousand people a year
but the demand just keeps growing we
sent jeremy j ford to talk with them
here in the three square food bank
warehouse they currently have an
adequate supply of food
but they're always in need of your
donations just donate
everyone needs deontay miles made the
trip to the food bank to drop off some
supplies it's huge to know that i'm
helping someone else that doesn't have
it's really heartwarming he tells me he
knows people are in need of food and a
small donation can make a difference you
can be helping someone who doesn't have
out
with their first or last meal of the day
three square ceo larry scott says due to
inflation more people are needing food
resources whenever there is some type of
impact to the economy we absolutely
always see a growth in the number of
food insecurity therefore a need for
more donations they're always in need of
meat proteins and produce and dairy
they're the three principal items that
every household needs anyone who is
looking to donate to the pantry can go
to eight newsnow dot com and find the
link in this story to three square dot
org for more information jeremy j ford
live local now